on this episode I do the last episode of
the year
yes
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 172 of the askgaryvee
show the last one of the year as
tomorrow I go away off the grid I'm not
fully off the grid off the grid starting
really Monday for at least five days
Lizzie and I get to go away by ourselves
this is a big deal
super pumped and they'll be in Florida
with the family I will be mainly off the
grid so I'll make my Jets football
predictions for the last three weeks
right here right now the prediction is
heartache I feel I feel it Jets are
gonna end up really strong but I'm very
worried about the Steelers and the
Chiefs running the table and when you
wouldn't Doug double-digit games and you
don't make the playoffs that's heartache
I don't know if you guys know that but
that's heartache to me that's the
ultimate heartache so I want to take a
moment before we go into the show to
thank all of you for this year it's been
a tremendous year we put out a lot of
shows as a matter of fact who oh we have
a recap we do oh it's an edited recap
it's an article that's the thing we did
yep so we'll have that later look for
that and we got a lot done got wrote the
book got a new website started the day
levy grew the team grew Vayner was a
great great year most of most
importantly everybody was healthy and
and for the most part happy I'm always
happy and and I just want to thank all
of you for your attention which i think
is extremely valuable time is the asset
so for you to watch this show listen to
this show allocate your very valuable
resource of time to care about what I
have to say about things is greatly
appreciated and so I wish you were a
healthy healthy healthy New Year and a
great 2016 and we will be coming back
with fire two to three daily DS a week
in 2016 so that should be an interesting
thing to see a vault and India for what
the last time in 2015 are you get
sentimental should we don't answer no
weird well do it like bros like yeah see
it's not I'm not doing like you know
weird yeah like like
Broz okay breasts let's get into the
show see that was good the second we
brought up that was probably our best
one yes yeah see the bro part I'm
telling you this is what this is why I
do this a lot you know I don't know if
you know I do this a lot exchanging
energy with amongst humans I think is a
grossly underestimated thing to me you
don't you don't know this but I've never
really said this but your transformation
physically was definitely not was
definitely a chipping away point for me
I'm very proud of you yeah thank you
thank you well tell tell the
vaynernation who you are and a little
bit about yourself okay
oh wow Tim Ramos I worked I started
working at Vayner probably in June 2012
when I graduated from college and have
been here since I love it
what else what else do you love like
work-wise know like walks on the beach
puppies like the New York Jets I love
myself yes that is by the way that is
you know what that just recaps the
show's entire existence good job buddy
all right let's get into this the real
good the real Kim Barrett okay because
there's a lot of Kim Barrett's out there
all right
Kim asks how do you deal with employees
that slack off but are super talented
keep or fire I deal with them the same
way I deal with any kind of employee a
super hard worker but maybe slightly
under talented and in-between on both
fronts every situation in life let alone
employees only can be solved when you
believe there's issues and you have the
luxury and the responsibility and let me
say that one more time when you have the
luxury and the responsibility of being
the judge and the jury the pressure and
the onus is on you I can truly truly
believe that if there's an employee of
vaynermedia and there are some plenty oh
no not not plenty that's not there
there's some
our highly talented and underperforming
that it's my fault we haven't craved the
infrastructure for let them for allowing
them to shine their their bosses are not
clicking with them and so that's not
motivating them we haven't asked the
right questions of the kind of interest
they have we we serendipitously you know
the serendipity of what accounts they've
been Tim how many different accounts
have you been on in your career and of
those twelve I would have seen that some
are more exciting than others oh yeah
definitely the end I mean that's just
real right there's so much
serendipity different bosses that you
get people move around he mates things
of that nature and so you know I think
the way I deal with it is communication
you know I have a full slate today it's
the last kind of in the office day of a
lot of meetings trying to get in 10 5 10
10 5 10 minute meetings and a lot of the
conversation will be around that and so
I think it's communication I think you
know it's like hey Rick you know I think
you've got talent losing out of your
eyes you're clearly not delivering on
the hustle which is an important
variable here what am I doing wrong what
is vane are doing wrong
instead of saying Rick you're lazy you
suck you have to put the onus on you
when you're a leader when you're CEO
when you're the organization it's on you
you're creating the rules of the game if
you don't like how it's played change it
you like what you like that one took
that in all right I know that made me
think a Hamilton great Lancelot asked if
you had an opportunity to buy Instagram
or snapchat which one would you choose
and why I sent you this one because this
one was challenging to me I mean look
these are the two social networks they
are the two platforms that live within a
mobile device that people are giving
their attention to actually it's go
around the room real quick Tim Instagram
or snapchat what do you like better you
had to pick one one has to go away all
right Tim clearly establishing on the
show it's all about Brett yeah so for me
I would probably buy snapchat and here's
why because of those answer
I truly believe that Instagram is the
social network of the moment when I buy
things I like to buy for 24 36 48 months
out when I invest the way I built
vaynermedia we were selling social media
in 2009 and 10 you remember this like
people don't want to buy this as much as
they want to buy it now I like
projecting plus there's one other thing
about snapchat that makes me give this
answer snapchat is a I think that
Instagram was a moving the ball forward
in a Facebook Twitter world
I think snapchat is a complete different
paradigm shift it's a completely
different way to communicate it's got
different functionality 30 to 40 year
olds that have never used it are
completely confused by it I'm fascinated
by that that also feels to me like
there's a lot of upside I think a lot of
30 40 50 year olds understand how to use
Instagram
it's very native it's basically like
Facebook boom there there that's good
that's the vulnerability of snapchat but
I also think that's the upside if
explained properly which I think Twitter
never really fully accomplished
I think snapchat becomes a beast for me
watching the behavior snapchat is
chipping away on a daily basis and only
because of the way I like to buy
businesses which is what do I think is
the number one play 24 36 months from
now it's snapchat that being said I'm
hedging against that I'm not sold that
snapchat is the biggest social network
24 36 months from now because I do
believe the Facebook Instagram you know
whatsapp you know facebook Messenger
Monster is is in its early stages I'm as
bullish on Facebook as I've ever been
and so that's my answer
that's my rationale Amanda asks do you
use a meal prep service what do you
think the future of services like that
is I do not use a meal prep service I
use mic tells me what to eat but but I
think those are great I think look I
think everybody will have everything
they want within two to three hours and
that will get chipped away over time I
do believe in 20 years most people will
be able to have what they want within a
5 to 1 out 5 minutes 1 hour window I
mean the on-demand at scale hyper growth
is here and so I think farm-to-table
capable I think India will be able to
eat radish
from the farm in upstate New York as
quickly as somebody could literally be
like I'm okay I'm getting the radishes
for India like I really think that
infrastructure is gonna be here I think
I don't think people really project
technology well meaning in 20 years from
today so many of your jobs will be
obsolete so much technology will eat up
the jobs that so many people do at a
minimum wage or a lower income that a
lot of those same jobs in the same way
that a lot of uber drivers today used to
do something else that's been replaced
by technology when they were making
48,000 a year but now as an uber driver
they're making 92 thousand a year so
everyone's like oh this is so bad we're
gonna put you know these developers out
of business or or film developers out of
business or whatever it may be yes but
then all sorts of things get created
that are new too many people are just so
half glass full like 20 people are so
doomsday like when Indy watch some
goddamn radishes right now farm-to-table
in the office instead of going to
seamless and waiting 30 minutes for
whatever she's getting she literally
Hudson farms are not that far from you
literally within an hour she can have
like plucked out and on her plate and
she's gonna want that and she's gonna
pay a premium for that she'll pay four
dollars for those radishes instead of 87
cents because they're organic and
biodynamic and shmeil around whatever
new totally hand to hand like whatever
it is that's why so the future of food
services is gonna be good we're gonna
eat healthier we're gonna pay more for
it it's gonna come to us faster we'll
have more choices it'll be more
convenient we'll get to spend more of
our time on our lives
with people and other things we care
about not the process of shopping for
food or ordering food thank you there
was a lot of stuff in that question I'm
curious how many people picked it up
it's a challenge yeah it's not daily
challenging yeah but keep going
Matthew asks do you think custom apps
are now or are becoming more crucial to
businesses custom apps I'm not sure that
means he'll make like a banner media app
like yeah got it okay so the understood
and so what is the question this is
always a hardcore debate for me look the
answer is if you're a business today
going through the next half decade 2016
through 2020 and you have the chops to
build an incredible app that people will
use like okay yes my just my belief is
that that's far and few between for even
the fortune 500 companies let alone
Rick's lobster roll stand in st. Louis
Missouri right so you know I think the
answer is yes but the commitment and
dollar amount and energy that needs to
be deployed to building a consumer app
that actually brings value to
individuals is very very very difficult
I mean even things that are hard core
utilities like banking apps like are
doing well but you know not as well as
you've really if you really think about
it just hard it's really really hard so
I would say for the 97% that are
watching here I would not recommend
building an app for your business
because I just don't think you'll build
the you won't be able to have the right
ratio of the cost of it
for yeah it's just they'll just they'll
be it's kind of like you know what it's
kind of like it's kind of like web.com
1996 95 97 98 I was there a lot of
people spent 50 100 thousand dollars on
building their website that their
website didn't bring them any value
because they make a good enough website
there wasn't enough demand for their
website I can see I know what's
happening now and I could see it getting
worse in the small midsize business
world of building apps oh yes
do you think it's necessary to learn the
rules before you can break them that's a
really good question do I think I think
the answer is no but I think you do
to pick up the rules as you go in the
beginning to then break them I think
it's okay to break the rules with
naivete and I think I'm thinking about
vaynermedia I didn't know anything about
the rules of agency world and I was
breaking them without knowing that I was
breaking them and then as I pick them up
for the last four years I continued to
break the ones that I wanted to break
and I also learned quite a bit from the
first eighteen months when I didn't know
if I knew the rules when I first started
vaynermedia I don't think we would have
innovated just as much as we actually
did so in a weird way I would actually
say knowing the rules upfront same thing
with the wine business uncom I'm
actually gonna go with a different way I
often talk about naive eyes not knowing
anything I think the really great
pattern is not knowing but then I
respect the game I respect the
advertising industry I don't just say oh
we do it better i watch I learn I pay
attention and so it's fresh naive eyes
that front don't know the rules break
them because you don't even know you're
breaking them and then as you mature
into your two three four five six into
your journey start picking up the rules
and then continue to break the ones that
you think are worth breaking especially
because what you learned in the first 18
months of not knowing the rules will
allow you to make really smart decisions
of which rules to break over months 19
through 72 mmm yep some people are just
smart I happen to be one of them I just
haven't look at the draw and I'll take
too much credit just mom and dad had sex
at the right moment and yes and that's
what it was it's really my favorite you
know why cuz it's ro if your mom was
like not tonight honey you would not
exist that's why that [ __ ] yeah anyway
we do not love our parents enough like I
love my parents the most still not
enough literally life like literally I'm
a tree instead yeah and I hate trees mmm
I literally eat everything but humans
yeah
okay what's the bonus question before I
get myself in trouble everything about
pets yes pets I just like humans sorry I
mean Jesus they meant like yes
a German Shepherd named Tyson after Mike
Tyson I love them
but I love people more I'm like sorry
yeah it's cool
Tim asks with all the money and time you
spend on travel and face-to-face
meetings how much of that could be
effectively accomplished with
high-quality digital meetings some I bet
you 30 percent of the things I travel
for would have been just fine on skype
the problem is the other 70% is too
valuable and I'm doing my best to
navigate and make judgment calls but I'm
a human and I'm flawed so that's the
answer yeah came out weird oh you don't
think I never say that I'm flawed it's
an ironic way to end I hope you have the
best best best Christmas for everybody
who enjoyed Hanukkah like myself I hope
you enjoyed that New Year's for
everybody and I can't wait to get going
in 2016 enjoy the downtime get your
sleep get your family time put your
hustle on if that's what you're into I
just hope the next 12 13 days are just
remarkable it's a great great time of
year I like that I always feel like
these are the two weeks where people can
really do what they want to regardless
of what they want to do just because the
world kind of accepts like okay we're
all gonna do our thing I like that I
like that a lot
thank you for watching question of the
day what are you doing for New Year's
and actually you know what that's crap
that's out question today I want your
2015 askgaryvee show recap I need
something to read my vacation so now I
really get in there I need a hard core
stuff I'm telling you right now like it
was good I might block you what's your
IP address you may never be able to
watch this show I don't need that that's
that's a half-assed thing for a show
that's been free for all year and all
the work that India's put in so I need
your recap your 2015 recap of the ask
Gary Vee show you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them